what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I was having lunch earlier today and
I thought crossed my mind about infinity
war and I was sitting here thinking I
wonder how people will react to it
because if the infinity war movie
follows the comic book material I think
it'll be one of those films that people
won't really grasp what they saw until
after they leave the theater and they're
on their way home and they're talking
about the movie and then the gravity of
what they saw starts to sink in I think
it's going to be absolutely
mind-boggling and I think the reason for
that is because of the fact that to my
knowledge I've seen a lot of different
movies there's never really been a movie
on the scale of infinity war assuming
that all the hype is to be believed for
the most part when it comes to movies a
deal with like magic and sorcery and you
know reality warping and powers and
things like that like they're always
grounded to a degree I mean dr. strange
was kind of as crazy as it got in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in terms of
abilities but even looking at like Fox
movies the x-men movies are the
fantastic four movies the Silver Surfer
you know had cool powers but it wasn't
anything insane it wasn't anything
outrageous I'd say probably the most
interesting display of his power came
when he absorbed a rocket into his board
but that's really more the fact that Fox
doesn't know how to make good movies but
with regards to the things that we've
seen in terms of powers they're grounded
they're relatable I mean take for
example Cyclops now you sit down you
watch an excellent movie you watch x-men
Last Stand or you watch x-men one or two
or you know any of the movies that he
was in and you see cyclopses optic beams
alright he shoots his optic beams at an
object and the object flies back or
something along those lines or maybe it
gets completely incinerated but it's
easily digested it's like okay he has
these optic beams and they're basically
a concussive force it's like getting
punched really really really hard and
the result is that you're just kind of
sent flying or you're totally
incinerated or something along those
lines but the idea is that's still
relatable to a degree storm would be
Fox's gateway to making a character with
just an insane amount of power the
Phoenix
sure but even then with the Phoenix it's
still kind of out there with storm it'd
be a whole different kettle of beans I
mean say for example that Fox decided to
make an x-men movie where storms powers
just went awry or storm just got really
pissed off one day and just decided to
just lay waste to the whole of humanity
she could do it I mean remember storms
powers are insane she controls to the
elements
to the molecular level she can't control
the earth and she cannot control fire
but everything else she can control she
can control pressure she can make your
head explode I mean she can do any
number of things with regards to the
elements of the earth I mean if she were
to lose her mind and just go crazy you
wouldn't be watching an Xfinity
you'd be watching an end-of-the-world
movie because then storm would start
conjuring these one-mile tall tsunamis
that would just descend on the coastal
regions of the world and just start
obliterating these cities she'd create
Dust Bowl she freeze over entire
continents I mean she would alter she
would fundamentally alter the ecosystems
of the world to the point that it could
be virtually uninhabitable if you think
that's impossible
go and look up something called the
Lituya Bay tsunami it was a tsunami that
happened in 1958 in Alaska and the
tsunami was 1,700 feet tall it was
taller than the Eiffel Tower it was one
of the craziest displays in the history
of the world and they wouldn't even that
long ago I was 1958 but again that's the
kind of thing that we're talking about
was you don't really see that and even
if you did you could still grasp it
because you would be like okay well
she's just manipulating weather patterns
she's just making it snow for like a
year or she's just making these giant
tsunamis or she's creating you know
tornadoes in Los Angeles wiping the city
off the map she's just doing these
things but infinity war it'll be
absolutely bonkers and absolutely insane
I mean not only are we going to see this
huge plethora of zeros or characters
that we've seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far we're going to see
characters that we haven't even seen yet
like they haven't even been introduced
yet characters that will probably be
introduced and Infinity Ward but that
begs the question with everything we've
seen so far are people ready for
something like Infinity Ward and I would
say no I mean people are excited you
know I'm excited but I don't think
people are ready to grasp something in
that extreme here's a really good
example imagine that the infinity war
movies taking place you don't imagine
that we get to this massive battle with
Thanos if Thanos has the Infinity
Gauntlet The Incredible Hulk and Captain
America and Iron Man who are all trying
to fight him at the same time and you
know Ironman shoots his repulsor ibly
repulsor beams and Thanos turns the
beams in the water and then imagine like
the Incredible Hulk
goes to attack vanos and battle
stratagem and throws in 65 million years
in the past
imagine that Captain America goes
superior shield and Thanos turns the
shield into flowers or snowflakes and
they just kind of dispersed harmlessly
into the air I mean that's what we're
talking about
just this insane display of power the
Scarlet Witch wants to use her you know
magic powers or whatever it is too you
know and he just kind of turns her into
like a tree stump or something like that
you know or he sends her a thousand
years into the future or swimming along
those lines and even then that's still
kind of tangible I mean in guardians of
the galaxy we saw a celestial that was
the whole story where the collector was
talking about the beings that use the
power gems and the Infinity stones and
so on and so forth and you know we saw
one of them who was just like wiping out
life on this planet or something like
that all right imagine an army of those
all right those Celestials imagine 50 or
60 of those Celestials powerless against
Thanos imagine that they're throwing
planets at him just hurling planets at
Thanos and nothing's happening he's just
casting them all off imagine that's a
physical manifestation of the universe
the universe comes down in physical form
and tries to fight Thanos and can't win
ends up being defeated I mean that's
what we're talking about that's an
insane Display of power and that's what
I think we're going to see an infinity
war and just that to me that's just
mind-boggling because we've never seen
anything like that in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Doctor Strange is as
close as we got but that was just some
small-time reality warping that was just
bending people's perception of the world
around them they're just magic that's
all that was I mean you saw the time
stone you know where you kind of rewind
time and different things like that but
that's just surface stuff that's
small-time stuff that's nothing compared
to the stuff that Thanos can do with the
time stone I mean it's crazy imagine
imagine like he starts de-aging people
imagine that like some somebody like
Scott Lang shows up you know Scott Lane
tries to fly panels and panels just
turns him into an infant he literally
winds his life back to the point that
he's an infant just sitting there and
people are laughing at I love it but
that's that's what I'm saying like it's
just a crazy Display of power I mean
it's almost indescribable in terms of
how it would all go down you know now of
course the ending of Infinity Gauntlet
was actually pretty awesome in
comparison to everything else that was
going on and again I think the movie is
going to come down to nebula I think
she's going to be the one that's
basically going to bring the entire
conflict to an end just because of the
fact that we don't have Adam warlock yet
and so I think this is when nebulas
going to get her time to shine I won't
spoil it too much but I mean at this
point the story's been around for 25
years or something along those lines
have been around for a pretty long time
so most everybody knows what
happens in Infinity Gauntlet but the
fact remains here that this movie is
going to be something that I think it's
going to change the world of comic book
movies but that begs the question where
you go after something like that I mean
it's like Lord of the Rings right like
Lord of the Rings came out it was nuts
it was Fellowship of the Rings and Twin
Towers of the two towers
it was The Return of the King you know
and then it's like where do you go from
there well you try to make the Hobbit
you just don't do as well but in Marvel
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe where
do you go after infinity war like what
do you do after a story on that scale
annihilation and annihilation was a
pretty cool story it was a story where
this villain named nihilus basically
invaded the main Marvel Universe and
tried to wipe out all life in existence
he literally did it with an army of bugs
it was called the annihilation wave the
problem with that is that Marvel has
either owns for is only introduced maybe
like a quarter of the people who were
supposed to be in that story there's no
Richard Rider I mean there's Peter quill
but there's no moon dragon there's no
file of L there's Ron the accuser but
he's dead there's no scroll race there's
none of that stuff like none of those
things about introduced creating that
movie right now immediately after
infinity war really wouldn't work you
know just because of the fact that if
the grand scale of the conflict wouldn't
be there I mean annihilation was
designed to be a story that Dwarfs to
deal with the events of Civil War the
Civil War was like this little skirmish
that was taking place on earth meanwhile
the universe is being totally
obliterated by Annihilus forces you know
and so because of that it was designed
to be this massive grandiose thing now
the problem with that is Galactus was
basically the one who ended the
annihilation wave Marvel doesn't have
the rights to using life just in film
form so you either have to find another
way or not do that story at all but in
truth Infinity Gauntlet Stan's is really
like the creme de la creme the precipice
of Marvel's cosmic storytelling and so I
don't really know what you do after that
I have no idea where you go but I do
know this I think that infinity war is
going to come out and I think it's going
to get rave reviews we're going to talk
about how awesome it is but I don't
think that people will be able to fully
digest what it is that they saw until
after the movies done and they go home
and they think about it and they're just
going to sit back and they're just going
to think wow
I've got to go see that again I know I
will
i obably go see it three or four times
to be honest I mean it's going to be a
great movie you know I've been really
really excited about the whole thing but
nonetheless I just kind of want to get
my thoughts out there and kind of talk
to you guys about Finiti war at least
how I view it I think it's going to be
absolutely bonkers I think it's going to
be a movie that changes coming book
films forever it may be something so
great that Marvel can never do anything
like it again and maybe it'll be their
swan song and maybe it'll just kind of
be all down you know downhill from here
I have no idea or maybe you'll just get
better you know I have no clue
everything's been awesome but at this
point no reason to believe it wouldn't
be awesome afterwards but still you know
it's just it's crazy anyway let me know
down in the comments section what do you
guys think Marvel will do after infinity
war I know that they've talked about
phase four and they said that like phase
four won't really be a phase it will
likely be just a whole bunch of you know
individual films I don't know I mean at
this point they're probably not going to
announce anything until after infinity
War part 2 comes out and so that's
probably 2019 before they actually make
an announcement on what phase 4 is
supposed to be any of it let me know
down in the in the comments section what
you guys think phase 4 will be what
movies you think they'll come out with
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]